thanks for joining us America in the
lobby a financial piece Plaza Julie is
with us hi Julie how are you hi Dave how
are you I'm better than I deserve
welcome I'm good you're here yes sir
I've done it where do you live I live in
Flower Mound Texas it's a suburban dfw
yeah yeah very cool and how much debt
have you paid off I have paid off a
hundred and eighty seven thousand
dollars even goodness it includes the
house however go however I did something
really stupid on the front end okay I
cash flowed boyfriend's golf range his
dream about a hundred and twenty nine
thousand dollars of this one hundred
ninety-seven no circle in addition in
addition yes sir I enabled someone you
cash flowed that yes sir
so that money's just gone is what you're
telling yes sir yes sir that's no fun
but you know I mean the way I look at it
is is that I'm the responsible one I'm
the one that decided to do that and it
was it was a boundary and you got a
master's degree in boundaries now yes
sir they don't teach you that in your
master's degree and at the University no
they don't
no they don't they don't they don't what
do you do for a living I am a global
Account Director for a logistics company
oh very cool and what's your income
I make anywhere between a 90 and 115 I'm
in sales so depends on how well I do in
each year how long did it take you to
pay off 187 it took me approximately two
years when I cash flowed it
I was basically putting all my income
towards his dream and after I found out
that we weren't going to get married we
broke up I I was burnt out so I went on
a hiatus for about a year or so and I
just just didn't want to think about
paying off the house or anything so yeah
so now you've paid off the house yes sir
half a house and everything I have
that's complete that you mean you've
done you've gone full circle all the way
from the Gulf
mess all the way to now the house is
paid for and you're weird yes sir I I
did and you know what I think what made
me realize that I was talking to my mama
and my grandfather was dying of cancer
and I was talking to her and I was gonna
get her the ticket and everything and
I'm like mom go out there and spend you
know at some time and she was like hey
Julie I can always spend about a week
I'm like what about two weeks what about
three weeks what about a month and she
said like you know Julie I got you know
dead I got all of I got a house payment
I got all that and it really it made me
remember back when I was a kid when me
and my mom and my sister walked into a
bread store and she had a dollar and she
gave that dollar and we got maybe a
couple loaves of bread and the lady
pulled up the little punch card and she
was like well mrs. garrison next time
you you uh next time you come in you're
gonna get some more bread and we went
out to the car and my mom started crying
and we went right back into the car and
right back into the store and we bought
some more bread and it really changes
your perspective I mean don't get me
wrong we never went hungry my parents
always provided a good Christian home we
never went hungry we always gave but you
know to go over to your little next-door
neighbor's house and see their cupboards
brimming with chocolates and and cookies
and everything and then you come over to
our house and there's you know bread
soup bread you know all the staple food
and you know it it put me back there and
you know what when my mom told me that
she couldn't spend more than a week with
my grandfather I was done yeah got you
back in the saddle then exactly for the
boyfriend knocked you out
yeah back up and go do that that's good
good for you yeah strong lady yeah you
know what and I'm so excited because I
want to encourage you know single ladies
out there everywhere don't enable people
regardless if you're a woman or a man or
a parent you know wanting to do the best
for your kids don't enable them don't
enable them
yeah that's calling it hard it breaks
your heart in an extra special way yeah
- so
that level of betrayal yeah and so did
the golf thing did it close up it didn't
make it
no he's he's still there oh he's still
there hanging on by teeth and nail you
know I wish the best I wish the best for
him I would be successful but you know
after being out of debt and had what I
didn't realize is I looked at the
financial part of it when we were going
out but I didn't realize you know that
is my baggage when I you know find that
extra someone special I'm gonna have to
talk to him about well this is what I
did and you know yeah he's still paying
me back solely but surely you know it's
it's that it's that back
it's that baggage but just don't pay
bills for somebody you're not married to
simple rule yes sir absolutely
absolutely but now the good news is I
mean when you get back after you get
back after it a hundred and eighty seven
thousand dollars in two years
what's this house worth the house is
worth two hundred and ten thousand
dollars okay yes for household are you I
do
I just turned forty two is for house it
was actually a goal you know it was um
the dishwasher went out in February
mm-hmm do dishes by hand yeah the you
know my AC and heater went out in
November paid cash got right back on it
even my boots are held up by some pins
no one ever knows you know what am i
know my more the jeans exactly you know
what my mom hates these shoes cuz I get
some new shoes I'm like you know what I
resold them and I'm gonna put a new zip
er and when I get home so you know it's
just amazing the things that you can do
and you know what Dave it's not about
money it's not it's about going out and
helping people and you know sharing your
story and and showing people how they
can get out of debt to you know through
financial peace a great program a
gateway that we that we provide great
program going out on mission trips
helping people that's what life is all
about and now you can live it like oh I
can't
I'm just so excited to make 100,000
bucks a year and you don't even have a
house payment and you're single you can
do any thing you want to do yes you'll
be able to live like no one else and
give like no one else absolutely put you
in the driver's seat I'm so proud of you
good job sir
thank you very good great just good
stuff all right Julie found Texas Dallas
Texas one hundred and eighty seven
thousand dollars paid off in two years
and a story to go with it now I need
it's one hundred and fifteen thousand
and income count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one well done
well done good job man sounds inspiring
you